He’s fearless.
He’s eccentric.
He’s dedicated to the SCP Foundation’s
cause.
In a lot of ways, he’s more like a living
legend than a regular Foundation employee.
His face, voice, gender, and even species
may sometimes change, but it’s impossible
to miss that ornate medallion resting against
his chest.
That’s right, today we’re talking about
the infamous Dr. Bright.
Can you think of many other researchers who’ve
been cross-tested with the dreaded SCP - 682
and lived to tell the tale?
Of course, there’s a special advantage Dr.
Bright possesses that most researchers don’t.
It’s the medallion he’s never seen without,
and because of it, Dr. Bright can’t die.
How is this possible, you ask?
Because, in a sense, he is that medallion.
Don’t worry - after this crash-course in
all things Dr. Bright - including his origin,
his present, and his future - you’ll be
a lot less confused.
So, who is Dr. Jack Bright?
For starters, he’s a decorated researcher
of anomalies for the SCP Foundation - and
unlike most other researchers, he’s uniquely
qualified for the job on the grounds that
he himself is an anomaly.
Just don’t bring this up when you’re talking
to him - it’s kind of a sore subject.
Beyond that, who or even what Dr. Bright is,
can be a bit of a loaded question with an
answer that depends on who and when you ask.
What we’re presenting to you here is one
of the more popular versions of the Dr. Bright
story, and the one most closely adhered to
by Dr. Bright himself these days.
One of our biggest challenges to understanding
Dr. Bright is that he has been so prolific
in his exploits and achievements within the
Foundation that when telling his story it’s
hard to know where to start.
But as the saying goes, let’s begin at the
beginning.
Starting with the Bright Family.
“Bright” was a name that carried a lot
of weight around the Foundation even before
Jack Bright signed up for service.
His parents, Dr. Adam and Evelyn Bright, were
both Foundation personnel.
His siblings were incredibly numerous and
the ones we’re aware of are TJ Bright, Mikell
Bright, Claire Pierce, and a nameless sister
now known only as SCP - 321.
Sadly, you’ll soon see that the story of
the Bright family is one of consistent tragedy
and strife.
While the anomalization of Dr. Bright took
hold a little later on in his life, his brother
TJ was born anomalous, and was designated
as SCP - 590.
TJ had the ability to heal any ailment with
a touch, with the cost being that he took
on those ailments himself.
He’s now used as a tool for healing at the
Foundation, and he’s consistently bedridden
with the illnesses he takes on.
Dr. Bright induced a mental state similar
to that of a three year old in TJ, likely
in hopes of reducing the mental burden placed
on his poor brother, and sadly, that burden
goes far beyond healing the illnesses of strangers.
When Adam and Evelyn experienced a tragic
stillbirth, they desperately tried to get
TJ to help.
TJ did manage to save her, partially, but
the result wasn’t human - and both he and
the daughter, which came to be known as SCP
- 321, were taken into Foundation custody.
SCP - 321 was a highly regenerative and stretched-out
abomination that seemed to keep growing with
age, but Adam still saw it as his daughter,
and spent the rest of his life trying to negotiate
her freedom from the Foundation.
When his request was denied as a researcher,
he climbed the ranks to personnel director.
When his request was denied there, he became
a site director, and then a member of the
O5 Council - all with the intention of getting
his daughter back.
But that never happened, and the rest of the
Council had him assassinated for his trouble.
There’s no reward for sentimentality at
the Foundation.
The other two Bright siblings are believed
to be polar opposites.
Mikell
Bright is one of the Foundation’s best field
agents, known to some as Agent Cowboy.
His dedication to the cause and incredible
aptitude at his job has led some to speculate
that he may even be on the O5 Council already.
Claire Pierce, on the other hand, disagrees
with the actions of the Foundation on a fundamental
level - which is understandable given the
horrific things they’ve done to the Bright
Family.
She defected and became a member of the Serpent’s
Hand - a fringe group dedicated to blowing
the lid on SCP Foundation secrets.
This brings us to the man himself - Dr. Bright,
the most well-known member of this sprawling
family.
Much like most of the rest of his family,
he too entered the employment of the SCP Foundation.
He was a junior researcher, and a relatively
unremarkable one, until his fateful run-in
with a certain necklace labelled SCP - 963.
But what is SCP - 963 and how exactly did
Dr. Bright come into contact with it?
It all started in a small apartment that was
raided by the Foundation due to supposed Occult
activities.
There they found a single body, cause of death
apparently from suicide, clutching the medallion
that would later be designated as SCP - 963.
The walls in the apartment were covered in
ritualistic supernatural symbols, and a number
of Occult books were also found near the deceased
man’s body.
The Foundation gathered that the man was attempting
to perform some kind of magical ritual, but
had apparently failed, leading to his own
demise.
The Foundation soon learned that the recovered
medallion appeared to be utterly indestructible,
and they placed it under the care of a junior
researcher - one Dr. Jack Bright.
Dr. Bright studied the medallion for years,
with very little to show for it, until one
fateful day when he was tasked with transporting
the medallion to a different area of the containment
facility.
While Dr. Bright was carrying out his simple
transport task, he made a simple decision
that changed the entire course of his life
forever - He held the medallion in his bare
hand.
He also happened to be walking past the containment
chamber of SCP - 076 - 2, aka Abel, just as
a containment breach was about to occur.
Abel is an immortal, hyper-violent warrior
who can summon blades out of interdimensional
portals.
Dr. Bright, following in the tradition of
Bright family bad luck, happened to be right
in the path of Abel’s rampage.
The ensuing battle between Abel and the assembled
Mobile Task Forces and guards resulted in
the destruction of the entire wing of the
facility, and Dr. Bright was cut down in the
brawl by the warrior’s supernatural blades.
It seemed like the story of Dr. Bright was
short and simple - cut down in his prime in
the line of duty.
But a few days later, as several members of
D-Class personnel were cleaning up the mess
caused by the containment breach, one unlucky
D-Class - known as D1-113 - happened upon
the medallion that Dr. Bright had been holding
when he died.
He leaned over and picked it up, and instantly
underwent a sudden and drastic change in personality.
D1-113 was now insisting that he was Dr. Bright,
and since this D-Class had no reason to even
know of the recently deceased researcher’s
existence, he was immediately brought in for
an interview.
After a brief evaluation, it seemed clear
that somehow this D-Class really did have
the exact mind of Jack Bright.
But how?
Well, after some experimentation - including
from Dr. Bright himself - they found the answer.
The medallion’s purpose was to act as a
kind of vessel for the consciousness of the
person killed holding it.
Its original creator had hoped to use it as
a way to attain immortality, and took his
own life in order to complete the ritual.
This was a mistake though.
The correct way to complete the ritual was
being killed by someone else while holding
the medallion, something that had happened
to Dr. Bright by total accident.
In a sense, he’d been given a second chance
at life, but this came with some anomalous
side effects.
As it turns out, coming into direct contact
with the necklace - now known as SCP - 963
- 1 - is a death sentence.
It causes your mind to be totally wiped and
replaced with that of Dr. Bright.
If the necklace is then removed, you become
a lifeless husk until the necklace is placed
back onto you.
If the medallion remains in contact with its
host for a period of thirty days, Dr. Bright’s
consciousness becomes permanently bonded to
the body without any contact from the medallion.
If the medallion then comes into contact with
someone else, even if a permanent version
of Dr. Bright is already inhabiting another
body, they too will be infused with his consciousness.
That means that if Dr. Bright wanted to, he
could have multiple versions of himself existing
at once.
Initially, the anomaly that Dr. Bright had
become was treated with suspicion and fear
by the Foundation.
They were dealing with an intelligent and
now immortal consciousness capable of replicating
an unlimited number of times.
In theory, he could even place his consciousness
into dangerous SCPs and gain even more power.
Dr. Bright was placed under strict rules - like
not being able to interact with certain anomalies,
and having his hosts killed and switched at
thirty day intervals to prevent him from building
replicas of himself.
However, this caution proved to be misplaced.
Dr. Bright was an extremely intelligent, loyal,
and devoted researcher for the Foundation,
and as a result, his restrictions were slowly
lifted by the O5 Council.
Much like his father before him, Dr. Bright
rose through the ranks, becoming both a celebrated
researcher and a director of various sites
during different periods of time.
While this may seem like a win-win scenario
for all involved, this is a slightly more
complex situation for Dr. Bright himself.
In a routine psychological evaluation led
by Dr. Simon Glass, Dr. Bright shared feelings
of frustration about his current situation.
He felt as though he was treated differently
compared to the other researchers and given
less trust due to a situation he didn’t
choose to be in.
But for Dr. Bright, the psychological effects
of having been fused to SCP - 963 - 1 actually
extends far beyond workplace frustrations
and the boredom and sadness of un-asked for
immortality.
In a conversation with Level 1 Researcher
Dr. Frederick Heiden, Bright told him that,
in a sense, he truly was the heart of the
Foundation rather than just one small part
in it.
When asked to elaborate, he said that, because
of the gift and curse of immortality, he would
go on to outlive all the other human operatives
working for the SCP Foundation.
He would remain with the organization for
generations to come, perhaps centuries even,
and in that sense would be the one constant
from now until the Foundation meets its end.
When all else is gone, only Dr. Bright will
remain.
Of course, this is just an overview and we’ve
only just scratched the surface of Dr. Bright’s
actions and activities across the SCP Foundation
multiverse.
But for now, all you need to know is that
Dr. Bright is still out there, and he’ll
be carrying that doomed name long after everyone
else with it has fallen.
Whether that’s a good or bad thing, is up
to you to decide.
Now go check out “SCP - 082 - Fernand the
Cannibal” and “SCP - 4000 - Taboo” to
get your Foundation fix from SCP Explained!
But why stop there?
Want to access some of the SCP Foundation’s
greatest secrets, but don’t know where to
start?
Subscribe to SCP Explained and turn on notifications
- we’re your guide to the strangest anomalies
and darkest corners of Foundation lore so
subscribe now!